keeping the valley healthy that is the
goal of the American Heart Association
of Southern Nevada here to talk about
all things heart health related Chris
Callaway joining us from the Heart
Association and local neurologist Dr
azine osma thank you both for being here
so early this morning you've got a big
event coming up this weekend the heart
borrow which we'll get to but first
Chris let's talk about why this
organization is so important we've been
drumming it into people's heads let's
remind them one more time that's why
we're here and the mission of the
American Heart Association is to be
relentless Force for longer healthier
lives and I think all of us Heather have
know someone or have experienced heart
disease and stroke and there's still a
lot of work to be done for example one
in five deaths occur from cardiovascular
disease so every 40 seconds someone dies
from cardiovascular disease or stroke so
during our conversation five people will
die from that see and you and you hear
those statistics and it really does kind
of Boggle the mind a little bit and yet
it's still continues news so Dr Zane
let's talk about uh you know or Dr osma
I'm sorry some of the symptoms and signs
that you may notice or things that you
can do to prevent this from happening to
you or your loved ones absolutely we
like to use the acronym um it initially
started with fast fast and now we've
added be fast to include more symptoms
so B is for balance coordination balance
making sure you don't have dizziness e
is for eyes so sudden loss of vision
blurry vision double vision and then
fast f is for face facial droop numbness
a Hold Your Arms out make sure there's
no drooping on one side or the other
speech s is for speech lowering speech
not being able to get your words out and
then Tia's time as a neurologist we
always say time is brain so call 9-1-1
get help as fast as you can of course
but you don't want to have to get to
that point you want to take steps
preventative care to think about it now
so that you and your family members are
live long healthy happy lives now the
big event coming this weekend the Heart
Ball this is a a great event every year
let's talk a little bit about it because
folks there's still tickets available
and you can still go yes yes you can get
the tickets and learn more about it at
lvheartball.heart.org and we're going to
have rock this town as the entertainment
okay some fun some fun great dinner
silent auction live auction and we'll
have our passion speaker to remind us
why we're all there and they are a heart
transplant Survivor so so you get to
have fun you get to meet friends and
colleagues in the community but also you
get that moment we were talking during
the break that moment of pause where you
realize that this is something that is
killing so many of us and that's the
goal of the event yes yes we want to
raise more funds for research since 1949
the American Heart Association
Association has raised five billion
dollars
for research and we still realize it's a
long way to go we've managed to reduce
the prevalence of heart disease death
from heart disease by 60 since 1950 but
there's still so much work to do the
research has helped fund things like
pacemakers artificial heart valves the
first artificial heart valve so we want
to continue to educate the public about
the signs of heart disease and stroke
and how they can help prevent it and how
we can help treat those who have it well
really
event is that the world of Astoria
per person or per table about 300 per
person okay great and again you know
that money is going toward research as
you heard it's going to something that
we can see and feel so again
preventative care but look for the signs
thank you both for being here this
morning good luck with the event this
weekend Folks at home we'll have this
information on the website for you if
you'd like to head on over to the event
and have a little fun all right